moi aussi
[Musique]
toi
je l'ai toujours dit avant à dix-huit ans mais j'ai
j'ai 18 ans je veux être chanteur sinon
oublie ça
[Musique]
ce furent les 12 heures les plus longues de ma vie
comme si j'étais juste du vent, ne le fais pas  il
n'y a rien, le concept n'est pas entendu, je n'entends personne
dire que ce n'était pas
mon rêve, ce n'était pas de devenir célèbre ou juste d'
être à la télévision, c'était une bonne chose, c'était
de devenir un artiste à succès
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes tous humains et nous voulons tous juste une
chance, une chance dans la vie, une chance dans une
éducation
[Musique]
Je pense que c'est sur cette cuisine opulente
d'un point de vue global
[  Musique]
Je me sens horrible d'exclure les gens des
choses que j'ai créées pour eux
[Musique] [
Musique]
venant de ma culture, nous aimons
exprimer notre liberté et embrasser notre corps
[Musique]
tout ce que vous avez à faire est d'aider une personne sans
rien attendre en retour